e
thank you everyone I apologize for the
I hereby open the executive session on
House Bill
102 and recognize representative
um saborin D
sha to make a motion of
retain the motion that we retain The
Spill chairman
Roy and representative LEL did you wish
to say I will second the motion to to
retain thank you would you like to speak
to your motion representative as written
this this bill needs needs more work we
like the idea behind it but it needs
more work to actually see how it would
be act acted upon in real life thank you
would you like to speak to your second
discussion seeing none I'd ask the clerk
to call the RO the motion on the floor
retain Vice chair Roose
yes
representative lels yes representative
devoid yes representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
saborn dwier yes representative Summers
yes representative Harry gther yes
representative
Muse yes representative Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes uh chairman Roy chair votes
yes 130 130 the bill is
um
190 I open the executive session on
House Bill 1 190 and recognize repres
representative lels to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move
ought to pass on uh HB 190
FN seconded by represent restive here at
gaite would you like to speak to your
motion
Representative no that's fine okay
representative representative Harry
gther would you like to speak to you a
second no okay well it's cannabis um I
don't think we need to say any more than
that motion is ought to pass I'd ask
clerk to call them call
[Music]
the vice chair roads yes representative
lels yes representative devoid yes
representative
DeSimone yes representative pette yes
representative saor dwier yes
representative Summers yes
representative Harry gther
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Shear yes
chairman Roy chot yes 140 140 motion
carries any objection to consent it'll
go on consent I hereby close the public
executive okay um we're just going to be
in on a break for a few minutes while we
pass out an amendment for the up coming
next spell and give everyone a few
e
all
I am opening the executive session
on House Bill 191 and I am going to
introduction
and I am
introducing amendment number
0756 H
second seconded by representative rhods
and I'm going to recognize myself to
speak to my
Amendment so we heard the testimony on
and while I may personally agree with
the sponsor we we had a commitment to
our constituents that we were going to
leave the abortion laws the way they
were however during the testimony it
occurred to me that
frankly adults shouldn't be taking other
people's children without their written
permission for surgical procedures any
surgical procedure at
all um which is the impetus for the
amendment that I brought
now I know some people still have um
concerns with the part where it says
that notorized written permission and
the reason for that in in my mind is
because well it's twofold one you can't
bring a successful prosecution in that
case without proving the person knew the
signature was false it was a false
signature and you know kids forging
notes goes way back to um Epstein's mom
if anyone remembers that I probably
dated myself to um to uh welcome back
Carter um
but I feel like it's it'll be very
difficult to prosecute someone for that
if they um if it's not notorized and
second of all any surgical procedure is
scheduled um well well well in advance
as some of us know it could be months
and that's plenty of time to to get to a
notary if you're going to have someone
take your child to for a surgical
procedure notaries nowadays I mean you
can go into any Bank they're in there
for free if you're a customer they're
they're all over the place we have
several in this building um they're
everywhere so I feel like that wasn't
that big of an impediment and so that's
the reason for my um bringing this
amendment we you like speak to you a
second chairman thank you I just would
like to uh make a brief comment because
you brought up about notary and I think
that there you know there is some
confusion but exactly like you said the
notary isn't necessarily signing
something to say that they agree or
disagree with what you're asking them to
notarize they're signing it to
acknowledge that the person that is
signing is indeed who they said that
they are um and they're
also they don't have to have anything to
do with anybody's medical records They
again are just certifying that this is
indeed that
person yeah thank you that's that's
that's an important point that they
don't generally um even read the
document um other than to look at what
what the nature of it is and who's
signing it they're more concerned with
the identity and um verification of the
person signing further discussion yes
representative n um I thought it would
be helpful um just on that note because
I have been a notary I am no longer a
notary and possibly things have changed
um this is also in a different state but
um as part of my record keeping I needed
to keep a copy of um the license of
anybody that I was notor um verifying
their identity and also whatever they
were signing so there is a there is an
element of needing to to keep what
you're actually having them sign so that
does get retained at least as far as I I
I don't recall that I've never seen that
that's a matter of fact I just had a a a
pretty significant um legal thing in I
I'd have been very upset if they told me
they were keeping copies of it um
representative thank you Mr chair uh I
still being a notary
um have never kept a document a copy of
a document because that's personal
information um some people do and and
that's fine however um if you look at
the um oath that you are supposed to
make the person who is signing
it take the oath says do you solemnly
swear that the document you are signing
is known to you it is true to the best
of your knowledge and you sign it of
your own free will act indeed and that
is when the notary would sign the
document if that person says no to any
of the previous questions it
behooves but it doesn't Force the notary
to say okay I'm not signing this uh but
I never in I've been in notary
for 30 yard years i' I'm I personally
have chosen not to keep any of that
information because it's private yeah I
think that I don't think there's a
statute away so I think that if if if a
certain notary wants to and the person
agrees to let them because they can
always say well no then I'll go to
another notary but I would I would also
point out that the document we're
talking about isn't anyone's medical
records it just says I you know Joe
Smith give permission to to Steve Smith
to take um my child to an appointment at
this place it it doesn't have to have
any particulars other than what they're
doing um yes represent Murray thank you
Mr chair um I have have a couple
comments um one I wanted to share my
experience recently trying to get
something notorized I do Communications
and marketing and on Facebook you have
to get um verify your identity if you
want to do advertising around certain
subjects and it took me hours to one
find a notary you know UPS tells you oh
there's a notary here I go to The UPS
Store there's no notary I go somewhere
else all the notary is out for the day
then I go somewhere else finally the
third place I went I could get the thing
notorized I had to wait in line it took
hours and um I'm not a parent with young
children or who works during the day and
is trying to balance work and um in
child care and I think that this could
present a significant barrier that's
also going to disproportionately impact
lowincome families who um I think I've
paid up to $40 for a notary before
occasionally um those kind of expenses
do add up and I also have questions just
around like how this is actually
enforced
um you know is there someone in the
hospital who's checking that the person
who's bringing the kid um you know has
this piece of paper signed saying that
they have permission to bring the child
there um yeah just not really sure how
that is um actually enforceable in any
way um thank you I I would I would say
that it's it would be enforceable um
after the fact type of a thing um for
example if you found someone took your
child and you went to the police and
said this person took my child for a
surgery and I never gave them permission
to do that that would where this would
be in advance there's no Gatekeepers
keeping people from medical appointments
it's more of you know this is something
you're not allowed to do if you break
this law you could be charged um with
regard to the notary I would I would
Point everyone to um www.1 notary.com
it's one of literally hundreds of online
notaries across the country that you can
go on and within I would say it took me
15 minutes to get something notorized
and it was $25 a document so um and it's
getting more competitive all the time so
I would say that while I understand your
concern I would suggest you open your
aperture and look online there's
notaries everywhere um and furthermore
if you're going to go to a surgery like
I said I would think that you've got
plenty of time in advance when you know
when it's going to H because we all know
as um healthc careers today you're not
getting a surgery anytime soon um if you
need one can I represent you can thank
you Mr chairman uh last year I tried to
take my two of my grandchildren to get
their ears
pierced the person that was doing it I
handed her a notorized
signature of my daughter and
son-in-law along with a copy of the
children's birth certificates and they
said we still can't do it because in
another state we need separate notorized
letters from each of the parents
separately not both so in other states
my point of this is in other states that
is what they requiring in order now
that's just an
earpiercing they're
requiring two signatures two separate
parents notorized in order to do even a
simple procedure like that so that's why
I like this who knew the ear pring was
so contentious um you wanted to respond
represent Murray I see
uh well that's actually helpful to know
cuz one of the things I was wondering is
if we have something like this regarding
anything else like in Statue like other
you know to take a kid on vacation you
know do you need a notorized you so
that's what I was curious if there are
other places in Statue where we have
something similar to this but um yeah
the en the enforcement piece is just
kind of what makes us feel like it
doesn't make sense to me because if
there's not a way to like stop it up
front then what really is um the point
of this other than like you're saying
after the fact but after the kids had a
surgery now you're going you know what I
mean it just doesn't really like make
sense to me but I guess my only response
to that would be um under that theory
then we should probably get rid of the
murder statute because you can't charge
anybody with it until after someone's
stand representative Sher
well I'm tempted to respond to the
chair's uh a baffling combat about the
given that there's a private right of
action um you know it doesn't matter
whether the written consent that was
given to the doctor's office was
notorized or not that the private right
of action is still going to stand it
doesn't make it any harder to prove uh
that a misdemeanor occurred if uh the
document provided uh to uh the doctor uh
was notorized or not uh uh so um I you
know in the in the limited number of
cases where somebody's actually going to
forge their parents signature um I I
don't think it's going to be that hard
to prove that that's what's happened and
that the fact that it is notorized um or
not is isn't really going to make it
different so I I I
I I in that vein I also share uh sentive
Murray's concern about you know people
of less economic means both parents are
working or you know a single parent has
two jobs it's in theory it's easy for me
easy for the chair to find a notary it's
a total pain in the neck for somebody
who's living their life out straight um
and so I I you know I would be
supportive of this bill the word
notorized wasn't in it to be honest with
you what um and what if any response do
you have to the the online notaries are
available
247 yeah I I don't know how many people
are aware of that you know you know if
if this isn't going to happen but if we
did a great advertising campaign that
the online notary service was available
uh but I I I just I just think it's a
requirement that doesn't get you that
much more to have it worth having it
there further discussion represent
M yeah the one of the problems that I
have with the amendment is it takes a
bill uh that was vague to start with and
makes it even more vague um I think the
bill that came before us originally was
very clearly uh an anti-abortion Bill
and what this amendment does is it
disguises that um and
uh I think that um
I think one of the things that I'm
concerned about is just the chilling
effect that a law like this in the books
um could have with people who find
themselves uh in this situation um I
think one of the biggest issues is you
know for a lot of folks is is is who do
you trust and unfortunately there are
some situations where the parents aren't
the people that uh that the young person
for one reason or another decides to
trust um and I think criminalizing uh
behavior of folks who try to help people
in that situation is something that we
should avoid
doing thank you um see no further I
would ask the clerk to call the role
amendment um Vice chair Roes yes
representative pu yes representative LEL
yes representative devoid yes
representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
sorn D Shir yes representative Summers
yes representative Harriet GA no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no uh
the clerk votes no representative Newell
no representative Shear no chairman Roy
chair votes yes 97 motion carries 97 the
motion is adopted that I recognize
myself to make a motion of ought to pass
as amended second seconded by
representative rhs further discussion
I'll recognize myself to make a mo uh to
speak to my um
motion I I hear all the concerns um and
uh I I I could go either way on the
notary part um but I I feel like I'd
rather start there it it's like I said
it's not difficult um to get something
notorized nowadays you can literally do
it in 10 minutes without even getting
dressed um but I I also understand that
there could be some people unaware of
that as many of us here today apparently
were representative Murray thank you Mr
chair um what representative Muse was
just saying reminded me of um one of my
concerns with the bill being around it
not including other family members um
I'm the oldest of five I've taken many
of my younger siblings to um medical
appointments particularly when one of my
sisters um was actively going through
cancer treatment and I was bringing her
down to Boston two to three times a week
because my parents were working during
the day um to get her treatments and to
add um an additional burden in a case
like that of going and getting you know
would I have had to get a notary every
single time um I know that that case is
um you know was not surgical at least
not every single time I brought her down
um but I just just think that there are
a lot of families that have people that
um are helping taking care of the kids
you know grandparents there's a lot of
mixed families in our in our state and I
do think that this will make it um
harder for them as well to to get
Medical
Care thank you anything
further uh seeing none I would ask CL
col the motion is ought to pass an
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes representative LEL
yes representative devoid yes
representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
Sabor D Shir yes representative Summers
yes representative Harriet G no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no the
clerk votes no representative Newell no
representative Shear no chairman Roy
chair votes yes 97 97 motions carries um
bill is
adopted if you are going to be doing a
Minority Report if I could ask you
please to have it to me by um tomorrow
if you could um by the end of the day
tomorrow they have to be in Wednesday
morning so that gives you something to
do during the session tomorrow um and
with that I close the executive session
I'm going to jump a little bit out of
order I'm going to open the executive
session on House Bill
recognize actually I was going to ask if
anyone wanted to make a motion on this
one do you
okay I recognize representative Murray
to make a motion I make a motion of a to
second absolutely I think um you know
we've as a body have passed uh bills
legalizing cannabis again and again the
people of New Hampshire have made it
clear that they would like us to
legalize cannabis um I think this bill
is a common sense compromise not getting
into the weeds shall we say with uh
dealing with the retail aspect of
selling cannabis but simply focusing on
legalizing it while ensuring that um
individuals out in public aren't going
to be exposed to cannabis um without
their consent so I think that this is a
good Common Sense compromise bill um and
that we should pass it out to
committee thank you representative Sher
would you like to speak to your second
uh I support report what representative
discussion I'm seeing none oh wait a
minute representative PR did you want to
say something no okay um seeing none I
asked the clerk to call the role the
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
appr you can V who you want no represent
LEL no representative devoid yes
representative DeSimone no
Representative
pette no representative saor deir yes
representative Summers no representative
Harry goite yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Shear yes chairman Roy chair votes no
97 M motion carries uh
97 again same thing on the reports
please if we could by tomorrow thank you
see I open the executive house executive
session on House Bill 206 I rep
recognize representative LEL to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I uh move
ought to pass on SB 206 FN I second that
um would you like to speak to your
motion I just think it's time that we
take this step uh it's it's
understood that uh uh we need to have
more discipline in the schools
uh for this sort of thing so I I think
it's it's time that we take the step to
uh uh
phones represent you might be on the
wrong bill is
206 um this
is6 you're looking at I'm sorry you're
in the Senate
uh if you recall but would you like to
um speak to your motion on this bill
though I like that
one let me let me pull it up yeah this
is the um police entry onto no
trespassing land yeah I apologize Mr
chairman if you could go to someone else
forness I'll speak to my second
um this bill would uh require law
enforcement to get a search warrant to
enter onto your private property um
where your private property is posted no
trespassing currently there um is a
rule at the Supreme Court level it's
called The Open Fields Doctrine whereby
if property that you own that your house
sits on but is not part of the curtilage
which is defined as the area right
around your house that you regularly use
the law enforcement doesn't require a
search warrant to go on that property so
for example I own six acres um the area
right outside my properties got some
Woods got a a shooting range
theoretically the law enforcement could
walk on there and look around anytime
they wanted to um I don't post it so I
don't care but if someone went to the
extent that they wanted it posted and
they didn't want people on there um I
feel like law enforcement needs to
respect that the way that other citizens
have to respect no trespassing signs now
we did hear um from our law enforcement
to their credit they said it's their
policy currently to get a search warrant
already if the land is posted no
trespassing and I commend them for that
um seeing that they're already doing it
anyway I don't see a problem with
putting it into statute just so that we
understand and if there is a case where
they don't get one they can't fall back
on the Open Fields Doctrine further
discussion represent
Murray thank you Mr chair um I was
trying to go back in my notes to see
exactly which a agency had testified but
I think what's hard with this is the um
broad applicability for um across
agencies that wouldn't be getting search
warrants so I know that there was one
agency and then Municipal officials that
also came and testified concerning that
this bill would um interfere with their
ability to do tasks such as surveying
land and that they don't have the
ability to you know it's not in their
practice to go requesting search
warrants so I think if this one had um a
more limited scope specifically to law
enforcement it would maybe be um more
amendable to passing but as written they
had concerns that it would interfere
with their ability to complete their
responsibilities thank you um it's my
recollection that we had this bill last
year when we passed it
um and the this year's version I I
thought limited that considerably back
from the broadness that that was there
be just because of the concerns that
were voiced by some I I would however
say
that it it doesn't app most of the
things that any municipality would have
to do are part of the building in the
house they there's no reason for them to
go into the woods behind someone's house
um surveyors are generally hired by the
homeowner I don't know that a survey is
ever done for tax purposes because they
already had the plats but yeah go ahead
represent M thank you chairman um I
found the notes it was it was the
Department of Transportation um and they
do land surveys you know when they're
doing projects around highways and that
sort Bridges you know that sort of thing
um the bill only has an exception for
fishing game authorities so they um from
the Department of Transportation had
said that they would appreciate an
explicit exception for their Department
as well um the New Hampshire Chiefs of
police had also said that they were
concerned um with it preventing law
enforcement from delivering civil
notices or chasing a runaway that might
go into um private property um and
oppose the bill as well and then yeah
the um Municipal Association didn't take
uh a strong position but said that the
definition of government agent would
include Municipal agents um and that
they would be subject to the same
processes but again don't have the same
access to requesting a search warrant
that law enforcement would have thank
you um again my only response would be
that um this would only require a search
warrant from someone who is going to
search their property and the results of
this there's no penalty other than
whatever they find would be inadmissible
so um for example the the power people
who were doing a survey um there's no
nothing would happen to them if they
went 20 feet onto someone's property
other than the fact I would say that
currently if it's posted no trespassing
I don't think that they can go on that
property anyway um without talking to
the owner first so it's really um I
think we're we're arguing about how many
angels could dance on the head of a pen
um further discussion representative uh
share um I I share representative
Murray's concerns and also being a
constitutional law nerd um I share an
additional concern uh paragraph two
lines 18 through 23 carve out
exceptions uh and two exceptions to uh
the to the law and and those are two of
the well very brief lesson about search
warrants there are a number of search
warrant
exceptions um and and two of them are
consent covered by paragraph Roman
numeral 2A another one is exent
circumstances covered by paragraph B2B
but there are other search warrant
exceptions that by the way this is
written
don't function as exceptions uh by
Statute so what we're doing is amending
constitutional federal constitutional
and state constitutional law to only
validate two search War exeptions rather
than any other search warn exceptions I
don't I don't think uh that was probably
intentional on the part of the drafters
uh uh who probably weren't aware of the
other exceptions uh but that's a problem
the second problem is the way the
exigent circumstances exception is
written suggests that all you need is
exent circumstances you don't also need
probable cause and uh I think that's a
drafting problem but
constitutionally even if you have exent
circumstances you still need probable
cause I think that was a drafting
mistake I don't think that was intended
so those are my
problems thank you further
M I think one of the things that we
heard uh repeatedly during the public
hearing was that um the folks who are
actually responsible for administering
and enforcing the law have problems with
this bill uh the marac County Attorney
had a problem with it uh David Goldstein
uh from the Chiefs Police Association
their chair of their legislative
committee uh opposed the bill and one of
the reasons he opposed the bill uh is
because he believes it may impact the
timely service of protective orders um I
think part of the issue we run into
sometimes on bills like this which I
classify as a bill in search of a
problem um thanks to a National
Organization that's been trying to get
it pass in New Hampshire for several
years now um we don't where are the
cases where were the people complaining
to our committee that they they had been
uh you know somehow offended because we
didn't have a law like this or how their
privacy wasn't being
protected um we didn't hear from them
what we what we heard from were law
enforcement people and and a county
attorney who were basically telling us
that this bill has problems and and you
know uh when you combine it with the
fact that literally nobody showed up
other than the sponsor to actually argue
for why the bill was necessary uh and we
had a bunch of very creditable people
lined up to tell us why the bill is not
necessary I think that's pretty
compelling reason for us not to pass
this
Bill thank you further discussion um I
would just say that with regard to the
um the service of process or any other
reason someone would legitimately um
want to be on someone's property the the
way to serve process is to walk to their
front door and knock um if you have to
serf process in the woods behind their
house um there's some questions about
that um this bill does nothing to stop
anyone from going on someone's property
and going to their door this is strictly
about people's property not around the
curtilage of their home so with that I'd
ask the clerk to call the road the
motion on the floor is ought to
pass Vice chair roads yes representative
Pro I'm going to go
no uh representative LEL yes
representative
devoid yes representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
saborn dniir yes representative Summers
yes representative Harry cite no
representative muse no
representative Newman no representative
Murphy no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
Shear no chairman Roy chair votes yes
88 88 motion um
fails and the bill is open to further
motions make it I move in expedient to
legislate
Motion in expedient to legislate by
representative um Muse and seconded by
representative Harry
gaite um I think we heard everything
about why everybody doesn't want it um
yeah after this one fails yeah um I'd
ask cl to call the role motion is
inexpedient to
legislate Vice chair Road
no representative PR yes representative
LEL no representative devoid no
representative D Simone no
Representative pette no representative
saor D Sher no representative Summers no
representative Harry goth yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy the chair votes no 88 88 that motion
fails as well I Rec recognize
representative roads to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move to retain
house B
second um I'd ask CL call the RO the
retain Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes representative
lels yes representative devoid yes
representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
some suborn Desir yes representative
sumers yes representative Harry Gite no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no the
clerk votes no representative Newell no
uh representative sheer yes chair no
excuse
me chairman Roy chair votes yes 97 997
the motion carries the bill is
retained
that I open the executive session on
House Bill 226 and recognize
motion um I think that I ought to pass
um
what
wait no I said
226 I didn't understand him
either
minut um I vote itl on this bill um when
I asked a lot of question okay you just
make the motion first sorry that's okay
second seconded by representative rhs
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you um I just still had some
concerns because I asked a lot of
questions for this one and they were
unable to clarify uh the who's the
what's the Wares are going to be
carrying this uh equipment and that's
pretty concerning for
me represent Ro you like to speak to you
a second yes thank you Mr chairman um I
know that I know that this bill brings a
lot of emotion and
respectfully I believe I understand the
intent of the bill sponsor and the
problem that I had with a similar bill
that we passed last year was the amount
of substance that is was allowed to be
carried on a person and this year I
understand that they're they're changing
uh some terminology because you know
terminology is constantly changing and
but there were several concerns that
were brought up one was if if this um
illegal substance is taken and it is
found that it is you know tainted then
what happens to it that that was an
unanswered question um additionally I I
remember there was testimony um from my
colleague from Portsmith and he and he
was very passionate and he said that you
know he's confident that one of the
reasons that you know that that overd
deaths are going down is because we've
taken um an all all the above approach
however nothing in this bill does
anything about helping people with
substance abuse
it's it to me it is it is very enabling
and I do not like the idea of you know
just a small amount that that is left up
to
interpretation um and I would like to
see I would like to see some kind of an
an effect to help these people instead
of just making it easier and
additionally
um as far as the all are above
approach we are ignoring the fact of the
people that are actually pushing and
pedaling these these substances onto our
parents onto our children and they're
dying so until we're going to hold the
people accountable that are pedaling the
drugs I'm not going to continue to vote
to allow it to
happen thank you Representative no thank
you Mr chair um I apologize I wasn't up
to speed we skipped one but uh I do
actually have an amendment for this bill
I handed it I will I will um I'll
recognize you um
to introduce an amendment that will end
up probably being like the minority
Amendment and it'll go to the floor with
okay um and and the point was a little
bit of a drafting error on my part I'm
sure is is you know to take out the
nominal amount um but what we did with
this bill just to to refresh everybody's
memory because we we did actually pass
this bill out of committee last year and
we passed it through the house the Full
House last year um and it died in the
Senate but but we we passed this bill um
so I I think it's interesting that we're
rehashing and especially considering we
passed a similar version of this bill
but it was a bill that allowed for more
than this does so we we explicit went
and spoke with um with interested
parties and folks who who may have had
some concerns with the first one and so
we went and we said all right we we
couldn't get this past Senate how do we
actually make this a passable Bill and
so what we have before us with the
amendment of course is the the kind of
you know streamlined uh really taking it
down to its heart and so explicitly what
this does um is that it allows for um
organizations harm reduction
organizations and public health
organizations that are registered with
the Department of Health and Human
Services so not just anybody not these
things are not just for everybody this
is for organizations that we explicitly
entrust with uh with matters of harm
reduction not we're we're not talking
about um penalties here because this is
this just isn't that those aren't going
to be registered with dhh this is
looking at it from a different way so
when we see um in all of the the above
approach we're not going to have all of
the above approaches in one bill this is
a bill that speaks to to one thing that
is missing from our our uh from our
system that that would help us uh that
would expand our capacity to be able to
understand um what substances are on our
streets as quickly uh as possible so
that we can respond effectively and
immediately so that we can be nimble and
address the issue as as it comes um so I
just yeah I I just wanted to to make
sure that that's said because really we
we put a lot of work work into making
sure that this was a passable bill um
and addressing the concerns that folks
had last year so I really I really hope
um um and yes it is it is emotional I I
I do really hope that we take a second
thought um and and think about passing
this again in a you know a thank you
further discussion a representative here
at
gther I'm just a little surprised just
as the um sponsor is um if we could save
one life this bill would be worth it for
me thank you thank you represent
Muse so one of the biggest concerns uh
from last year was uh the inclusion of a
nominal amount so uh it was the idea
that somebody uh who was let's say
testing a pill for the presence of
fentanyl would be able to have some
small amount of that drug uh for use of
testing and they wouldn't be prosecuted
for having that what we've done this
year is with uh representative n's
amendment is that's removed so it won't
be legal to have any quantity of a
controlled substance under this bill
what what the bill does though is it
offers the same level of protection for
people in those Public Health agencies
and people who are actually engaged in
testing these drugs that we currently
confer uh to people who work in Labs who
test therapeutic cannabis if you take a
look at our therapeutic cannabis statute
one of the things that's put that's
actually right in there um is an
exemption for those folks from being
prosecuted for possession of Controlled
Substances while they're actually you
know doing this type of lab testing so
there's precedent for what we're doing
and I think there's there's a real need
for this bill um and i' I'd be the first
to tell you I don't want to take any
tools away from law enforcement um when
it comes to enforcing our drug laws but
what I absolutely would like to do is
put more tools into the hands of of
people with the potential for saving
their lives I mean this I think one of
the things that that has been proven uh
over the years with uh Technologies like
fentanyl test strips um is that not
everybody uses them but people do use
them and when people use them they
really can make a difference and they
can save lives and it's great to take a
hard line um but I think the hard line
ends when it's your kid you know and I
mean if if if you had if you had a child
who was in that situation a kid who was
off at college for the first time and
had fallen in with uh some people you
would have rathered them not to fall in
with uh would you want them to have the
presence of mind to use something like
this before they consumed the drug and
the answer to me will be yes my
preference is never that they use the
drug but if they're going to do it you
know damn it make sure it's not going to
kill you and and that's what we're
accomplishing with this
Bill thank you for the
discussion I would say that speaking for
myself um I'm not sure what happened
with the bill last year I thought we
actually passed it I don't recall if I
voted for it or not I thought that it
became law or some version of it did in
the last session um having said that um
I've done some research myself and I I I
you know with regard to trying to find
out what kind of dangerous drugs are in
the system well we we already have
someone doing that and they're the
police when they arrest someone and they
have drugs on them they are sent to a
lab and they are tested because you
can't charge somebody without proving
that the substance they had is a
controlled substance so the police
generally speaking know what drugs are
on our streets and they make it quite
known that um you need to watch out this
drug is out there that drug is out there
as they try to interdict these drugs I
don't think that this will add anything
to what they're already doing um other
than allowing people to take their own
supply of drugs to go be tested um I I I
just frankly I I've never I can't
Envision a situation where someone who's
purchased some some Sentinel or some
heroin is going to travel about to a
place to have it tested um before they
use it generally speaking it goes pretty
quickly into their system so um while I
I I 100% support the the the emotion and
the the thoughts behind trying to save
people this way I would say that it's
redundant um we're already paying law
enforcement to check on the supply of
illegal drugs and I really wish we would
spend as much effort to try and and get
rid of these drugs off our streets
totally than somehow giving tacit um
approval of their use by allowing people
to have them checked um I'd ask clerk to
call the role the motional flow is in
expedient to
legislate Vice chair roads yes
representative appr yes representative
LEL yes representative devoid yes
representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
Sabor dwier yes representative Summers
yes representative Harry GTH no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no the
clerk votes no representative newel no
representative Shear no chairman Roy
chair 97 97 um it's my understanding
there'll be a minority motion um
Amendment um being submitted with the
Minority Report is that
correct
okay and with
that um yeah I learned about that myself
it's new um with that I close the
executive
session and we are going to take a how
I'm going to open the executive session
on House Bill
321 and I recognize representative rhods
to make a motion thank you Mr chairman
um I move Amendment 20250 0347 H um was
given out last week and I believe there
was extra copies over on that table if
anybody is looking around for it
47h I second would you like to speak to
your motion sure thank you Mr chairman
uh so this this bill uh when it was
brought to us it it was one that I think
we all actually really really liked um
and the intention from the sponsor was
to say look I'm I'm trying to pay the
fine that you know that I received um
for making the speed limit be maybe more
of a suggestion and
but sometimes people just need more time
to do that so you know what he did was
during you know while he was testifying
their re questions as far as you know
making it be you know the initial 30
days and then asking like for two
extensions and so forth so uh what this
amendment is doing is basically replace
all for the bill it is giving the person
the opportunity to to make their plea
either in person or online and it gives
them from the initial start 90 days pay
the fine and then if the 90 days comes
and goes and you know they're they've
made their good faith and they need an
additional time this allows the DMV to
come up with a set of
rules to allow for an additional 90 days
to pay their fine um I would just like
to say I as an example if it's Christmas
time and you know a person's a an hourly
employee there's probably a good chance
they're not going to be working for
maybe four or five days you know for
that whole entire holiday season and uh
this would just give somebody the
opportunity to not be in more trouble
when they're trying to correct what they
did thank you uh who made a second
representative Sher would you like to
speak to your uh motion yes uh briefly
um I worked with uh representative a the
prime sponsor on this bill uh on the
underlying bill um and the idea as
captured by representative roads is you
know there's there's people who have
less significant means uh to manage
things like fine
uh that uh and and it would just want to
create a little more looseness in the
joints um so that we're not sending them
off to court and suspending their
license and doing all the things that
come with failures to pay fine so it's
just opening the window a little bit
broader and I think it's a good idea
thank you represent Murray thank you Mr
chair um I appreciate this bill on the
amendment for sure I
um maybe 8 years ago now when I was in
my early 20s got a speeding fine um that
was over $200 and I absolutely learned
my lesson I never sped that fast again
but at the time um I barely made over
$300 a week um and that fine it I
basically you know had a month of eating
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
because I had to pay almost a week's pay
for this fine in that 30-day period so
um I appreciate that we're passing this
hopefully out of committee otpa and that
other people won't be in the same
situation in the
future thank you see no further
discussion I ask the clerk to call the
role the Motions to adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative po yes representative L
house yes representative devoid yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative pette yes representative
Sabor dhir yes representative Summers
yes representative Harry gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chair votes yes 17 Z 17 Z the motion
carries would you like to make another
motion thank you Mr chairman I move L to
pass as amended for Bill 3
21 further discussion would you like to
speak to your motion think we covered it
anyone else
see none and ask clerk to call the role
motion is ought to pass with
Amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes representative LEL
yes representative D void yes
representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
saor dhir yes representative Summers yes
representative Harriet gther yes
representative
Muse yes representative Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Shear yes chairman Roy
chair votes yes 160 160 any objection to
consent seeing none go on consent I
close the executive session with that I
open the executive session on House Bill
343 can I recognize representative
Murray to make a
motion um can I actually go upstairs and
grab the printed Amendment for
this it's already okay we're going to
are you adding are you adding fake
members to this committee I just was
like no nine and seven
16 all right I got to go down and just
see
go yeah I just want to go see if
I I'm GNA go down and check we've got
checking yeah I said yes yeah I keep
checking in they said they need a
hour after you submit it by email they
reject
it
e
okay I'm going to open the executive
session on House
Bill
194 and recognize representative roads
to make a motion thank you Mr chairman I
moved to retain House Bill 194 a second
uh would you like to speak to your
motion oh thank you um although I I left
my notes in in our office in there I let
me rephrase that I I heard the the
frustration um there are many people
that testified and you know about child
custody
and I I don't see that the way that that
particular bill was written that the
concerns that the the people have are
going to be addressed in in that bill um
The Way It Was Written things were very
very vague a lot of thing left a lot
open for interpretation and it left a
lot open for who would be responsible
for what when it came to the enforcement
of How It Was Written so um I think the
best thing to do is to retain it let the
sponsors come back let some of the
stakeholders come back and see how they
can make it actually be a workable
Bill thank you um I'll speak to my
second I think the the
foundation of the bill is a good bill I
think that it needs to be um clarified
narrowed distilled so that there's no
ambiguity or as little as possible and
um because the the law exists already
and it it is
Criminal it just seems that what we
heard from the testimony was people had
a really difficult time getting the law
enforcement to take action on it and
therefore it wasn't helpful um also I
want the sponsors to take into account
that violating an order already um is
potentially criminal um by virtue of
contempt of court should the court
choose to do so so I don't see um
necessarily that we need to increase any
penalties I think we just need to make
sure that law enforcement is aware of
their ability to enforce this and and
indeed obligation in some cases um so I
I I support the retaining the bill
further
discussion representa Muse
I would say that um this is probably a
bill that is less in our Strike Zone
than some of the other ones uh that have
that have come before us um and I would
say more time to actually you know
consider some of the implications and
some of the potential unintended
consequences you know including
potentially
um uh penalizing an overprotective
parent with a Criminal conviction I
think those are things that we need to
really pay close attention to yeah I
agree I'm I'm always very uncomfortable
um when 99% of a
law um belongs in another committee but
yet 1% sticks it with us and it's not
really our I believe uh one of the
strengths of character we show is when
we admit it's not our expertise so um
that that's important that all those
issues that are also being addressed by
the appropriate committee right now in
another bill um that touches on this a
little bit right now so I think that's
more appropriate representative share um
and and my concern with the bill has
always been um I just don't want to get
criminal I don't want the police to show
up at a scene when a a parent a divorced
parent drops their child off two hours
after they were supposed to and I can
see in the wrong in the very emotional
Circumstance the other parent uh calling
the police because of that it's just
child custody arrangements are messy
enough as it is to to have you know the
AG griev parent calling the police to
their return is just it's not a good
place to go no I I I think the the
problem that really this bill is trying
to address is
actually the backlogs in our courts is
really what the problem is is because
the appropriate venue to have this
discussion would be in front of the
judge on the existing order but the fact
that it takes them months to get in
there um by that time you know there's
there's 50 other things that have happen
so I I think the problem that we're
eventually going to have to face and
deal with is is the the um pressure on
our courts and the availability of
judges to actually hand out Justice um
see no further discussion I'd ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is to
retain Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes representative LEL
yes representative devoid yes
representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
saborn D schir yes representative
Summers yes representative Harriet gaite
yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Shear yes chairman Roy chairs 160 160
the bill is
retained that I open up the executive
session on House Bill 343 and recognize
representative Murray to make a
motion thank you Mr chair I move a to
pass an adoption of amendment
0499 H second thank you motion made and
seconded um would you like to speak to
your motion absolutely thank you um the
amendment I'm bringing forward um was
made after looking over the last report
we got on the Northern border Alliance
and most of this is uh information
that's already included in the report um
is mainly codifying it into um statute
and then it is requiring additional
information be reported specifically
around um the Customs and Border
Protection related in incidents and also
around um the individuals who are
being um otherwise uh engaged with
through this program they live um the
intention for that is if you look at the
last report I I said all the numbers
when I was introducing the bill but
essentially out of the like the hundreds
of people that have um had interactions
with the law enforcement through the
northern border Alliance program um only
four were cited as border related
incidents um so the hope is with getting
more of this information we can
determine one like how effective this
program is and what its intended
purposes are supposed to be and if there
are better ways um for us to support law
enforcement up by the border um whether
it's through this program or not but
basically we need the information to
make adequate decisions around funding
and how we support law enforcement up by
the border thank you um I will speak to
my second and and I will say that as a
supporter of the northern border
Alliance I think
that we should make all information
available um I uh we just passed a bill
recently regarding the federal
activities in the state we wanted to
know their information I see this is no
different I don't see any problem with
producing the evidence that a program is
either successful or as you said
unsuccessful and if it needs to be
modified so I think that this is a good
bill and there's no problem with
producing this information I went to the
Border this summer um I went up there
and took a tour and met some of uh the
fine Troopers who were working on this
and I also talked to members of the
public in the area um as I went around
and walked around and some of the
walking was out in the middle of the
woods um in the public I I found no one
who was not supportive of this because
of the fact that they are U many of them
who live up there on that border they do
feel that conquered in a way has kind of
forgotten them up there um they were
appreciative of the the higher level of
police presence in the area um and they
really liked the idea that they were not
alone up there and the federal um people
we had on the border were just not
enough and this was a force multiplier
for them so I'd be interested to see the
information that comes back from it as
well I'd also say on the report that we
already got I wonder if that just
reflects what our law enforcement did
versus what the federal government did
I'd like to see the difference between
that in other words are our law
enforcement helping on those but it's
not being captured because it's on the
other one so I'm I'm interested to so I
think it's a good bill further
conversation discussion see none I ask
clerk to call the role the motion is to
adopt the amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative pu yes representative LEL
yes representative devoid yes
representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
subor dineer yes representative Summers
yes representative Harry Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chair votes yes 160 160 the
amendment is adopted I recognize
representative Murray to make another
motion I make a motion of ought to pass
as
amended Maiden seconded further
discussion want to speak to your motion
or we all set okay I ask Court to call
the RO the motion is ought to pass an
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes yes representative
LEL yes representative devoid yes
representative D Simone yes
representative pette yes representative
Sabor disir yes representative Summers
yes representative harri gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chair votes yes 160 160 the motion
carries um any objection to consent
seeing none it will go on consent and I
hereby close the executive session I
believe that's all of our business for
today oh no oh we got one more I
think okay we're going to take a short
minutes yeah know I was trying to leave
I I couldn't um all right he was hoping
nobody would notic yeah too many people
noticed um we just we're going to take
five minutes while they talk about I
think what it is is I forgot that we're
yeah
e
okay I'm opening executive session on
House Bill
330 and I recognize myself for a motion
330 seconded by representative
rhods uh speak to my motion
bill this bill seeks to deal with the
problem of um restricting information
that's obtained off our driver's
licenses in retained by private
businesses or other other
people while I I 100% support the idea
that we heard during um we heard during
testimony at the hearing from numerous
private companies and organizations that
this would cause a lot of problem as
written um and that that's certainly not
what we're looking to do so I want to
retain it and take a second look at it
um and maybe if if there's something we
can do about it we'll do it again in the
fall um would you like to speak to your
second no thank you anyone discussion on
this seeing none um I'd ask cler to call
the role uh the motion is to retain
House Bill
330 Vice chair roads yes representative
PR yes representative LEL yes
representative lyd yes representative D
Simone yes representative pette yes
representative saor D schier yes
representative Summers yes
representative Harry cther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chair votes yes 160 160 House Bill
330 is retained I open the executive
wait a minute first I close the
executive session I open the executive
session on House Bill 146 and recognize
myself to introduce amendment number
0591 H that has been passed out to
everyone um you second seconded by
representative rhods I'll speak to my
motion okay so we know we heard from the
sponsor what the bill was trying to do
the bill is trying to we he had a
constituent who got a motor vehicle
citation
he appealed it as he should to the
courts um but part of his appeal that he
wanted to make the argument to the court
was that the officer was in some way
inappropriate with him and he sought to
use the body Cam and introduce it as
evidence in his defense by the time it
got
around the department had erased it as
per their normal procedures for when it
goes beyond a certain date so the bill
as introduced sought to put certain
dates and it get complicated and then we
figured out that the easiest way to do
this would just add to the existing body
Camp statue where it already says they
have to hold on to body Camp footage for
pending criminal cases or valid court or
administrative order Etc or we just add
it or violation level offense so if
there's a citation they've got to hold
on to it until it's disposed of um and
if the person pays it and there's no if
the time period goes by where the person
hasn't appealed the citation then they
can destroy it so it's pretty simple
further discussion question questions
it's a it says section one but then the
so let me let me Express why I ask that
question my problem with this bill has
been uh the uh section the 5day
requirement and and I
don't if this
replaces uh uh a but doesn't replace C I
still have the same
problem what I'm going to do I'm going
to I'll I'll recess this for for another
day this week if I can if he says it's
okay to Friday and I'll fix whatever
they did on this and check on that great
thank you are we good to do that okay so
I'm going to recess this until Friday
we'll take it up then with a better um
document that doesn't end with the word
ant and with that we have um house bill
I have to open house
spill
218 relative to police reports and I'm
going to recess that to Friday CU we're
waiting for an OS fix on that as well